Hey,
hello, hello, we are back for a second stream today.
This is our first solo stream of the week and the last solo
stream of the week.
And today was this week was more like collab week.
But today I'm wanting to play this game for now.
I just realized I didn't even realize there was Twitch
integration.
If I knew there was Twitch integration, I would have, I
would have done it on Twitch, honestly.
This would have been really fun.
It's like I remember when we did Call of the Lab, that means
I could like, I could judge you guys.
I could sacrifice you to the pit.
Brady, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The super is a celebration of stop killing games.
Officially having enough votes to make the EU listen.
Yeah, congratulations.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Brady.
But yeah, I've been looking forward to this game for, to
play this game for a bit.
So I'm super excited.
yay it's basically like i said it's basically like pay rich
please but with zombies uh but do not worry in new dope new
new doky line i shall be the savior of the zombie apocalypse
i shall build a safe haven for all humans for all dragons
all right we're gonna let's see i wonder if i can actually i
wonder how that works give me a sec let me i don't know if
sound guy is alive either so Let me check how Twitch site.
Okay, I'm going to sign into my Twitch.
And now I wonder if we could just use the chat.
Like, do I have to actually be live?
That's what I want to know.
I've successfully logged into my Twitch.
Okay, now how does Twitch integration zombie quarantine zone
work?
All right, let me try this.
Gladiator directly influenced gameplay by voting on events
through chat increasing interactions wait no
wait no wait i'm not i'm i'm i'm i might unlink twitch
integration all right all right all right let me double
check uh how does it work you need to add viewers give
permission choose symptoms and then should show give views
permission to extend and then choose symptoms and i think it
only works in endless mode and not in campaign mode okay all
right well um i'm not letting you guys into my game
i'm not gonna let you guys uh vote for the bunch that
happens in my game then let me let me not let that happen
Because I know you guys are just going to be like, more
zombies!
Did somebody say more zombie?
Guys, at one point, there might be too many zombies.
All right, I need to make sure there's no motion blur.
Oh, yeah, for those who are...
I hope everyone that's currently affected by the worst
snowstorm in the world.
Um, it's doing okay right now in America and Ontario.
It was in Ottawa.
I don't, I don't keep track.
They both start with Owen.
Like, the only, the only Canadian place I recognize is the
west coast of Canada.
Uh, oh, Ontario is on.
Oh, nice.
That, uh, for now, the worst storm for now.
That's true.
Global clueling does get worse every year.
Yeah, I heard like New York is really bad because of the
snow too.
Like, they're getting like how many inches of snow.
And at the moment, that's your own.
Yeah, but I only pay attention to the west coast of Canada.
Everything else is non-existent to me.
I think the worst part is just, I think snow is the worst
part too.
storm like what is it called ice rain i'm like what the fuck
is ice rain i'd like i was like is it hell and then my some
of my friends were like no ice rain is not hell it's like
it's like its own thing and i'm like but hell is ice snow
rain so i'm like you mean there's more than just like yeah
apparently it's like hell is like when the ice is already
frozen um in the clouds um but ice rain is when it's about
to it's raining and it turns into ice mid rain and i heard
that one was like that is like worse than regular hail uh
gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it
was minus 15 degrees celsius all day to the end i work oh no
gordon no oh it's called freezing rain sorry freezing rain i
got confused freezing rain ice rain is it's the same thing
yeah freezing rain is like a lot worse apparently i've never
heard of i live in canada and we never got freezing ring
before so i i did not realize like that was a real thing
there was an exploding tree warning holy america are you
okay or also ottawa too i'm sorry ottawa apparently ottawa
is like the coldest place in the world right now which is
like minus 50 degrees celsius i was like I heard about that.
I've heard about exploding trees before.
But, like, minus 50 degrees Celsius.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what it is in freedom units.
You guys can convert it yourself.
I have no idea what it is in freedom units.
But minus 50 degrees is fucked up right now.
That's actually fucked up.
I was like, bro, like, I feel like you take off a glove and
then you just get frostbite.
all right let's play this yeah what's this save as many
people examine evacuated and infected to give humanities a
chance wait okay which is more fun technically do an endless
mode do i get a tutorial guys which is more fun what do you
think also i'm wearing glasses because i'm a doctor my
wearing glasses it guarantees that you are a doctor it means
you are a doctor 100 of the time
campaign is more fun all right let's try it out i just feel
like chill i can't wait for high guard like my entire feed i
brought i swear to god if they got paid to glaze that shit
i'm i swear to fucking god like like i judged like because i
was like oh man maybe i judged the game too harshly but like
literally all my entire feed is just like all these players
that and all these people That no glazing the shit out of
it.
I swear to God if they got paid.
I swear to fucking God
Because there was no hashtag ad there was no hashtag ad on
those tweets and that's illegal That's that's illegal
That's pretty sus Alright, Kel, thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm gonna fall for it.
Yeah, I'm still looking at all these plants on my lawn to
protect me from these zombies.
Kel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, take the walkie-talkie.
Okay, I need a...
I'll do minor sense.
Here, it's too high.
Alright.
Take.
I swear to God, if I fall for it again.
Be honest, who here would have had this zombie?
100% me.
Someone down with me.
No names.
Even a super chat.
Thank you.
I will be on that plane and take it to another country.
I would be on that plane.
Because I'd be like.
Also because I'd be like.
Don't worry guys.
I'm pretty sure I'm immune to this.
It's going to be me.
I'll be like.
Guys don't worry.
I'm dead.
I might have been.
I'm a main character.
I'm main character syndrome.
I'm definitely immune.
I'm just different.
I mean, it's because, like, I'm gonna fucking die anyway.
I'm gonna fucking become a zombie anyway.
So might as well, like, help my team.
You know?
I might as well fucking help the team out, you know?
I'm gonna fucking die and become a zombie.
Gotta help the team out.
Wow, Toki.
I'm a team player.
How am I team humanity?
Have I fucking already got bit?
Also, I could be immune, too.
The possibility of me being immune.
We don't know if we're immune until we live through it.
And what if, you know, what if they cure me?
You know, what if I fly?
What if I, like, find out, like, guys, I have to fly to...
I don't know.
I'm trying.
Guys, I have to fly to Sweden, guys.
They said they might have found the cure for zombies.
So of course I'll hide the fight.
I'll be like, guys, I have to get to Sweden.
They said they found the cure to zombies.
I could be one in a million, exactly.
Guys, they need my blood for the cure.
I'm not taking any chances.
I gotta take her out.
Where's Georgie?
Oh, here.
Talk to Georgie for the bloodshed.
Jokie bird flu spreads after the first hour of being agreed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is why VT for hate is justified.
Let's see.
Welcome to the tomato fire.
Welcome.
You guys owe me 10 bucks.
Nothing personal.
It's just...
We're stuck in Groundhog Day out here.
Just trying to, you know, not go crazy.
Okay, so it's simple, really.
Just shout, next.
And the guys will let the survivor in.
Oh, yeah, those are the survivors.
Call the next survivor.
Okay.
Come in.
Am I lagging a little?
What's wrong with his eyes?
Okay.
all right toggle the flashlight hello all right examine i'm
examining i'm looking yeah i don't trust those eyes those
eyes look pretty up match what you see yeah bro is not
surviving i heard casos in here too yeah no he definitely
looks infected identify the particular ailment and click
symptom locked if you mark most symptoms correctly you'll a
reward game up these okay let me know it's better once
you've recorded the symptoms it's time to decide their fate
let's switch to the distribution tab the distribution tag
still not sure no worries just send them into quarantine let
them sit for a few days and the virus will reveal itself why
don't I just liquidate this can't piss in the gas tank not
sure what he meant yeah so to make for our safety we have to
make sure doki never gets bit nst thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you long one in pretty face pleading
eyes it'll come back to bite more than just you in the ass
just bird anyone that i suspect why you have to send them to
quarantine i don't i i'm not taking any chances remember
there's no cure liquidation of painful man be certain once
you send a survivor this decision cannot be reversed the
checkpoint field uh sent survivors here to investigate
unknown symptoms uh temporary accommodation for help send
all not you send survivors to a block even when it's full
but the survivors there will start to get sick and die okay
okay so obviously do not send sick people there all right
that's fine uh after expecting survivors okay i got this so
we'll take bribes guys i think in zombie apocalypse money
has no more value it's all about Could take food bribes.
That is true.
You gotta be kidding me.
Well, then...
I'm not my fault.
Your eyes are fucked up.
Also, I gotta fix the graphics.
Maybe I shouldn't play on high.
It's a little too much, maybe.
I'll do a medium.
Oh, I was gonna say.
I swear to God, the graphics is literally just...
Hmm.
There you go.
The one time, I don't think...
I don't think I...
need all right here you go okay there you go it's fine do i
need high graphics oh this looks icky wait give me this
looks pretty gross give me a second maybe i do need high
yeah yeah no i need high oh my god no that yeah no that that
looks actually gross that no I do not like that that
actually looks like not great mmm the medium I feel like I
don't have to look that far anyway all right here you go all
right next survivor hello hello ma'am please can we hurry I
think we were all right let me look look at you all right
symptoms wait i'm examining um he doesn't she oh oh yeah i
feel like yeah no that yeah true uh you have any bruises i
mean doesn't look like it fine.
I mean, your knees, though.
Are those from recreational or, like, oh, you are a little
dirty, too.
Hmm.
I mean, this tells me to send her in.
So, I think it's fine.
I think she's good to go.
You know what?
We will be evacuating the survivors' block.
The top brass will be very upset with us if we don't move a
adequate number of healthy people.
Oh.
Examine the survivors in the line and send the unaffected
onto the block They're always hiding it's under her shirt.
You gotta take it off Yeah, oh so I have I have to All
right, Chloe.
I have to find four people Okay, I get it.
So that's the campaign.
I gotta get as many survivors as possible All right, there
you go So as long as I hit the quota, I can see oh Are you
sure this area is secure?
feel see too bad i didn't notice it here uh guys do you
think he's bit yeah you think yeah you're right yeah i think
he's he's fine right like it's just a really bad just really
bad pink eye just a little smooch yeah his girlfriend got
super intense yeah she watched he the rivalry and got
inspired uh yeah it could be a birthmark that is true that
is true we can't judge on appearance guys even though my
whole job is to judge by appearance yeah no he's fucked yeah
no um and the red eyes yeah um yeah extensive damage he's
like i don't think this person's safe i don't think you're
safe you're absolutely sure about this he just willingly
wants to walk to liquidation wow wait that's eat that was
easy you are in a quarantine zone stay calm and wait for
your turn remove your all right next he just he did um you
think he's a He doesn't know.
They're just like, oh, I'm going to get some liquids.
They're like, all right, send that guy to liquidation.
Oh, and they're like, finally, some water.
He has freckles.
And he has yellow eyes.
Other than that, he seems fine.
All right.
Yellow eyes.
Why is, okay, are usually...
He has freckles.
He's sick!
But some command...
Is there some kind of...
Do not...
The zombie rash?
Oh, he was...
Oh, my God.
He has freckles.
Shoot him.
Take him out.
I fucking knew it.
Freckles are...
Are the...
Are signs of the devil.
Alright, we gotta take him to quarantine.
Alright.
run he got ginger by something almost as worse as
zombification all right what's up with her someone's
watching us i know it oh no wait wait what is that oh that
is a nasty okay never i was like yeah she could be okay i
was like oh yeah that's a nasty bro oh uh you got nothing
you you too your girlfriend also watching the rivalry too
you're hey girl are you really really thirsty because uh we
got some extra water for you at um at our liquidation site a
bite we got a bite but toky she doesn't have that you don't
No, she doesn't have red eyes.
Uh...
She seems to have more guards.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's very safe.
Yep.
Yep, it's very, very safe.
Not that hard, right?
Also, can you try to avoid excessive executions, please?
We'd like to keep our jobs.
She got bit!
What the fuck do you mean?
Excessive executions!
Oh, I'm sorry.
Maybe I should put her...
Maybe I should put her in quarantine.
We don't know for sure.
guys they could have been it could have been her her
boyfriend or girlfriend being very excited guys you're right
you know it could have you know at at best it could have
been a dog bite you know she could have just got rabies i
mean we still have to kill her but uh there's no care for
rabies but like at least it's not a zombie bite
Like, you know, at least it's not death by zombies.
Death by rabies.
More upbies?
Alright, I got you.
Oh, yeah.
2,000...
Oh, my God.
Wait, this should be my new job.
2,200 in a day?
And I just needed to kill two people?
Wait, that shit's easy money.
The more people I kill them...
Wait, actually.
The more people that I kill, the more money I get.
What?
Any effect?
Nice.
I did it.
That's 1K.
That's 1K approval.
You mean, technically, I could just spread the virus.
Like, I can just, like, have, like, a little pet zombie and
just have to invite someone to buy the hand and be like, oh,
gotta take him to execution, I guess.
Alright.
maybe this is the zombie it maybe it's like 20 day eight
days later zombie apocalypse where it's only like seclude
it's only like uh what's the word it's only contained in the
united states or canada this could be canada we're in
celsius degrees here or it's only contained in canada so uh
so like i could just fly fly somewhere else and just use my
money Is it the survivor in quarantine?
Oh, yeah, we gotta check if they're...
If they turned or not.
Alright, inspect the court every day.
Send the survivor infected survivors.
Well, you must clear quarantine when there is a zombie.
Alright, Lurias can look and behave differently for
different.
Send survivors to quarantine.
Yeah, I know, but this is Celsius, so...
Wait, who's this guy?
Oh, yeah, he had green yellow.
Then pick an assignment.
All right, um, I guess I'll inspect them.
Hello?
Uh, I'm pressing it.
It says E.
How do I...
I'm trying...
Oh, oh!
What the fuck is this?
Is this for...
What is this for then?
Oh, that's to kill everyone.
Everyone
To kill everyone lever I was ready.
I was I was like I was thinking about it
Rob the same thing I was ready
I was ready for the money I heard that get eight hundred
dollars per person and I was fucking ready to touch that
lever Like, yeah, he was definitely a zombie, guys.
I don't really know.
Have you seen the Pathologic Games?
As far as that is, the only series that make you seriously
considering the selling your only gun and three bullets for
food.
If we're looking for something different, that fit the bill.
Bill, thank you.
Let's super chat, Dan.
Thank you.
But then I lose my gun.
Is that worth it?
But what about gun?
Also, like...
I mean, he seems fine.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, I could test his temperature.
Okay.
High and extreme, bro, I'd rather get this.
Wait, have I already purchased it?
Oh, I don't have enough.
I mean, should I send him in?
He doesn't see... I don't know.
develop yeah but shouldn't we wait a couple oh oh his eyes
are better oh i didn't even sorry i forgot to look at the
most important oh they must have found they must have killed
a deer oh yeah no he's fine all right go into survivor blah
we need more people there wait i need to check the other guy
all right let me check oh yeah he says yellow yellow eyes
sorry his eyes were up there and i was not looking at that.
All right.
Or is it?
Oh, there it is.
Use the thermal pulse to check a survivor's vital sign.
Sneezing or hiccuping.
Maybe signs of an elevated... Okay, okay.
Elevate.
Oh, signs.
Like, sneezing or hiccuping may be a sign of zombie.
I was like, Oh my god.
Bro, the zombie virus is fucking intense.
You just can't have anything.
And freckles, too, apparently.
The zombie rash.
I fucking knew it.
I knew they had no souls in them.
Use the tool.
Oh.
Sneezing and hiccuping.
Zombie.
Is that?
Oh, oh, sneezing and oh, that's not good.
Wait, what's the normal temperature?
Eat the getter.
Okay, 155, 157, 43 degrees.
Okay, 155.
And wait, what was 155?
Oh, wait.
I already forgot.
Sorry.
that's not normal right 155 and 40 oh 43 all right what is
it oh oh oh lady i'm sorry to say
um yeah no that there's your brain should not be alive right
now it's it's a little elevated just yeah just a little bit
your pulse is just a little bit fast guys it's just it was
155 right oh yeah it was just elevated it's not extreme it's
just yeah but she hurt but she was 43 though that's infected
that's liquid it's It's time to give her some Fiji water.
That's a sign of infection.
She's just really nervous.
Bro, her brain is mushed.
There's no way.
I'm sending her.
We could not.
Maybe she has a cold.
I swear to God, I will send her to quarantine.
If she turns into a zombie.
If she turns into a zombie, I swear to God, yes, I was
right.
Cool.
Yeah, I got cooler.
cooler fever with with liquids you're right i should have
done that i feel like i oh my gosh i have a feeling she's
hiding a bite mark like right here right on this shoulder i
can feel it all right let's check oh her eyes are yellow too
hundred and nine and thirty six hundred thirty six i mean
it's hundred and nine
Nope, it's just that, but her eyes are yellow, so I got it.
I'll send her in.
All right.
Quarantine time.
You gotta be kidding me.
What?
How is that poor inspection?
How is that?
She seems mostly okay.
Oh, yeah, fine.
I'll send her out.
Maybe I shouldn't.
All right, get over here.
I'll recheck you.
Wait, first...
But she has yellow eyes, though.
Look at her.
Oh, she...
Oh, 36 is lower than 37.
Guys, it's not my fault.
I was rounding up.
Look, see?
It hit 36.39.
And I was like, I'm rounding that up.
I'm rounding that shit up.
But she still has yellow eyes, though.
So go back in there.
I didn't realize, like, I had to get every symptom correct.
I didn't know that.
All right, go back in.
Go back in there.
At least it's not a death sentence.
Yeah, I'm rounding it up 0.5.
All right, next.
Oh, she's sneezing.
I know the rules.
I wouldn't be here if I wasn't okay.
Oh, and hiccuping, too.
all right let's see all right 37 and 122 all right 37 and
122 oh man i don't have enough all right i'm sending someone
to liquidation all right one might check her right yeah you
were there was something wrong with you oh let me double
check My kids just made it through yesterday.
I just need to join them.
Oh.
Yeah.
I don't think we have any kids.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
From what I remember, we don't have any kids at the safe
haven.
But we do have kids in the liquidation center.
That's where we put our daycare center.
Yeah, so let's just send you over there.
Is this another checkpoint?
Yeah, yeah, that's where your kids are at.
Yeah, they're at our newly established daycare center.
Alright, let me put you in there.
You seem more safe than the other.
exactly all right oh infected eliminated I got I got the
right I've lost too much already don't make me turn back now
I've lost too much already I don't think I need us I mean
it'd be it's just like oh man I mean wouldn't hurt to see
what else is wrong with you well good news is that good news
is that you don't have a fever it's like do you want to know
the good news or the bad news first good news luckily you
don't have a fever bad news Is that...
Is that...
I might have to...
Send you to a place to get, you know, those hiccups fixed,
you know?
I got...
Your hiccups might need a little fixer up.
162.
Oh yeah, this one.
So, hey, there's that.
The bad news is...
I'm still fine.
Huh?
He has bright eyes!
Oh.
Well, then.
Oh!
Infected- Oh, oh, oh, infected eliminated.
Oh, nope.
Nope.
Infected eliminated.
I still got it.
I still... It said they double-checked.
They're like, oh, I think you said it in a survivor.
But they double-checked the SAT.
I was gonna... I was like, there's no fucking way.
I fucked that up, bro.
The guy's eyes was red.
That ain't normal.
Oh, it's the Plants vs.
Zombies guy.
No, he seems safe.
Oh, my god he is it's crazy dave yeah wait that's cool he's
just crazy so like i think that's fine like
get this man i think as guys he's only crazy so i think it's
perfect for the survive for my safe haven oh it says send
crazy dave too that's like great that's funny uh let's check
you up already went through quarantine once i passed where
there's only one quarantine area what do you mean how do i
do you have a certificate for the other quarantine um do you
do you have the the qr code 187 jesus christ is that normal
yeah that don't apparently not I'm gonna be like, why are
you so nervous?
I thought you passed quarantine.
Huh?
You said you passed quarantine.
Why are you so nervous?
Huh?
That's a bruise, right?
Let me check.
No, that's just...
Oh, yeah, never mind.
Okay, never mind.
Yeah, yeah.
I passed inspection.
Yeah, all right, buddy.
Alright, that's another dog bite, isn't it?
That's a fucking ankle bite.
Sorry, that's your kid, right?
Biting your ankle?
Yeah.
Just a little tattoo before...
That would suck if you get a tattoo right before, like, a
bite-mark tattoo right before the zombie apocalypse.
They're like, I was just trying to be edgy.
Other stuff is there.
Yeah, that's it.
liquidation time so yeah I passed all right time to go home
yeah infected eliminated money money money must be funny in
a rich man's world boom wow wow
Yeah, past every inspection zone, my fucking ass.
Huh?
Prevent breach.
Perimeter.
What?
Breach.
What the fuck?
Okay, okay.
Okay, all right, now it's okay.
Now, oh my god, now it's drone time.
What the fuck?
Oh, what?
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Oops.
I got a little too excited.
all right now it's fps time oh that's bad i got a little too
excited i saw red and i was like zombie i
saw red i was like zombie oh that's bad oh that's so bad oh
that is actually so bad for me
Oh my god, this is actually Just plasmas and zombies without
the plants
Oh god, I'm reloading It's okay, okay, it's okay The wall is
safe Guys, new Doki Lon is okay
It's okay, it was just a simulation Now it's the real deal
Guys, it was just a simulation Now it's the real The real
deal Oh my god Don't worry, it was like, you know, like
those flight simulators before you get your license?
It was just that, guys.
It was just that.
Now, now, now it's the real, no, no, new, new, new Doki Lan
is still very safe, guys.
I wonder if I can.
Oh my god, I fucked up again.
Yes.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
It's very safe.
all
right see look at that look at it after the simulation okay
after the simulation we're all we're okay i had practice
there you go wait you what do you mean
what do you mean way Dude!
Oh no.
Okay.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're so safe.
Look at that.
Victory!
We're so safe!
We did it guys!
Now that was the real deal.
Just eight more ways.
All right, maintenance, 500, affected, eliminated, defense,
what?
Easy.
Oh my god, I have so much money now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I didn't admit any infected survivors.
It's a bare minimum.
Even made me hungry.
Remember, the better a man eats, the longer he can fight.
As for civilians, they don't last long without food either.
Make sure everyone gets fit.
What?
I have to be a chef too?
Switch to the monitor to campus or upgrade buildings or
purchase what?
Oh my god.
Are you fucking oh my god.
There's like There's like Civ management too.
I have to do the inspection and the fucking bills.
Okay Oh my god I have face management as well.
Oh my god.
Why do I have to do everything?
Do I not have, do I, is there no other people hired for
this?
I got promoted to a manager.
No extra pay.
Just extra work.
I am for a raw management.
This includes the survivors, provisions, power.
Where is the upper management?
I'm the only worker here.
It's just soldiers and me.
I was the only one that graduated high school.
and then get drafted into the army immediately
okay i thought the money was for me not for like the people
i'm not yet to do everything around here uh mr mg thank you
for super chat thank you thank you thank you sir i'm
thinking of a super chat thank you thank you we're boned
don't worry don't worry i can do this i can multitask I'm
very well known for multitasking.
Survivors go ahead, the more survivors we have, the more
food we don't need.
Buildings are how we meet the needs of survivors and demands
of our mission.
You'll now build and upgrade and increase housing storage.
The power is the lifeblood of this regularly.
Check on the generator and make sure it has enough fuel and
the total power does not exceed the...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, this is fine.
Alright, resupply.
spread things too thin okay how much do i buy six now you
know how to restock the mess okay 12 okay three is needed
for today one is sick oh you respond for i'm hiding three
critical resources to all survivors why is the food so
expensive what the fuck bro i'm feeding you guys spam and
canned beans you aren't where are we getting this food
inflation dokey
um then uh for us definitely spot canteen adequate value
meet these needs has for every essential Research conditions
will deteriorate.
Survivors who fall ill can be served to help with Medkit's
disdainment essential for maintaining a robust checkpoint.
A healthy survivor will become sick.
A sick survivor will die.
Okay, yeah, no fucking shit.
Okay.
Um...
Okay, then we have to buy...
I'll buy two.
I'll buy two Medkits.
Um...
What can I do with upgrade?
Treats up to 20.
Treats up to 10.
uh what's the power looking like power consume generator 14
fuel and generators okay resupply the fuel looks all right a
reliable starter model i need zone quarantine number two for
that how about beds we have enough beds we have 12 beds all
right that's good security tower
okay i need like level two all right get back to work i
guess i have to go back to work now wait unless oh i can
upgrade this too but i need zone level two all right
everything is fine it seems like my city is new doky lot new
new doky lot seems to be okay oh alerts and metal is
detected in the baggage what the fuck would they be doing
with metal
Alright, it's fine.
Everything looks good.
Alright, time to clock in.
Uh, I'm gonna go check the survivors now.
Oh, oh, his eyes are white now.
Alright, what about you?
Eyes are white.
Uh, alright, let's check you real quick.
That was his problem, white, right?
Let's check your symptoms.
Oh!
You're cured!
We did it!
Sir, congratulations!
You get to be a citizen in new...
Wait.
Oh my god, you zombie rashes!
God, you're no longer ginger!
Congratulations, sir!
Alright, you get to be in new new Doki Lan.
Get over there, survivor.
You don't have to be really, really thirsty today.
Alright, oh, it's still hiccuping.
I know the rules.
I wouldn't be here if I wasn't okay.
Alright, let's check you up.
Oh, you're still sneezing, too.
185.
82.
Oh, that...
Ooh.
Um...
Let me double check.
Ooh.
You're...
Um...
I know the rules and oh I I know the rules too and I know
today is also paid me a triple check just to be sure I am
gonna be getting paid for this all right well um are you
thirsty please just just tell me what's happening well just
just grabbing you a Drink real quick.
You know, you've been in there for a while.
Have you got any drinks?
We can fix her.
I'd give anything and everything to wake up from this
nightmare.
Dude.
Oh.
Um.
Ooh, that's awkward.
Look, she got better.
Her eyes turned yellow.
Oh my god, guys.
She got better.
Her eyes turned yellow after.
Yeah, alright.
Yep, I guess.
Go back into quarantine.
You're crying out loud.
She's healing.
Surely it'll go away.
Alright, come over.
Alright.
Oh, she is Hickey.
let me double check if he's had any bite marks on those
thick thighs that he's got oh all right you should do a teap
if i'm like the uh oh 138 and a hundred oh 39 40 oh oh 134
okay 40 oh you just made it you're so lucky i didn't round
up this time oh 47 40 40 oh he's just there he is just there
40.74 he's so close and then he has no oh none of he is he
is hiccuping though Hmm.
He is hiccuping.
Yeah, it's elevated.
Elevated and...
Wait, 120, right?
Yep.
Alright.
Alright, we're sitting.
We gotta make sure.
Alright, get in here.
Alright.
We should...
If it's like an airport inspection, what are they called
again?
TSA?
They should be giving me a T pose.
So rude.
Have you guys ever done TSA before?
Come on.
He's just very dirty.
I mean, he's not hiccuping or anything.
He's just dirty.
He just hasn't had a shower.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Those look like zombie rash.
All right.
157.
36.
Alright, 1-157, and then the zombie rash.
I'm just double checking if I have to round up.
Nope, you're safe there, except for the...
Except for the ginger vitus.
We gotta be sure, you know.
We gotta be sure it's not zombie rash.
I'm not sick, I swear.
Yeah?
explain those freckles huh nobody's born with freckles i'm
fine um i'm just yeah sure she's not wrong i'm totally fine
look into my eyes Hmm.
Okay, let me double check.
187.
Oh, yeah, no.
Is that red?
Oh, it's this cut.
Okay, here.
Yeah.
And then skin cuts.
Oh, yeah, I'll do cuts on your head.
Bro, what the fuck happened there?
Were you trying to, like, wear a barbed wire?
I mean, that's already enough for me.
Yeah, bruises, just so I can never get extra pay.
Alright, now we're sending over.
Alright, we have some Fiji water for you over there.
Am I in trouble?
Come on.
No, no, no.
We just, you know...
We noticed how...
This is just a bad dream.
Just a...
Oh.
Yep, just a very, very...
a very bad dream.
I feel like, I guess they don't know.
I guess the survivors don't know, like, what the symptoms
are.
And they're just like, oh, I mean, I guess they haven't seen
a mirror in a long time, too.
Because I'm like, why would you ever go?
They might be immune.
You don't know that.
They could be immune guys or it's getting cut yeah yeah she
just she just had a taste of the devil's lettuce yeah but i
mean like you know if i look in the mirror and i see red
eyes it's like i i guess she thought like maybe she could
bring i wouldn't notice and she's like me where i'm like god
you know gotta try and win for the team you know
I gotta...
You gotta...
You gotta help the team out.
It's like, maybe she'll get past the...
She'll get past the inspection.
Let's just get this over with.
Oh, that's a nasty bruise, though.
That's a fucking nasty ass bruise.
Oh, no, yellow eyes.
116.
Yeah, I would wear...
I feel like during inspection, though.
You know, during the inspection, you wouldn't.
36, 113.
The only issue is just that she has yellow eyes.
She's just sick.
So I'm like, I don't know.
Oh, man, I don't have enough quarantine spots, too.
Oh, I have to make a really tough decision here.
Oh, this is a 50-50.
Guys.
Maybe...
Maybe one of them got worse.
You know?
Penelope.
Hmm.
Oh, this is... I gotta make the decision.
I am full, though.
We have...
Five... You know what?
It doesn't matter.
I'm sending you to burn.
It actually doesn't matter.
I just realized.
Because we just need four infected.
Poor non-infected, right?
And technically, we have five.
So, like, I don't need you.
I made the bear...
I made the quota.
It's true!
I made the quota!
There's no way her eyes are yellow!
She has bruises and her eyes are yellow guys i don't i don't
think she's safe guys guys i swear to god it's over if i
send her i'll lose money why would they take my money i was
just trying like we already made the quota why would you
take my money like even if it's liver failure why the fuck
would I take her into new new Doki Lod she has liver failure
I don't have a spare liver for her
murder is murder well I'm just trying to keep look it's just
like you know it's like the trolley no she's how do you know
she's safe how would you know it just means there's a risk
here
oh wait it only means never mind i just read the whole
sentence all right i guess i'll take you to the survivor
block thanks for letting me live huh fine i guess you pass
did you hear that someone's watching us is paranoia sound
sign too also why would i don't know i don't why would take
such a risky person into my camp she does have freckles my
oh she can read thank god 106 and 36 oh then it's fine right
yeah only the worst thing is she has freckles she doesn't
seem to have any cup whoa this has to be the cleanest
survivor what the fuck how do you have bruise on your face?
This has to be, like, the cleanest survivor I've ever seen.
A lot of freckles.
That's pretty suspicious.
Yeah, wait, oh, wait, no.
No, the kicks are definitely not clean.
Like, where did you have access to clean water?
Alright, well, the only thing I can notice is just a bruise
on your head, so I guess you're pretty safe right oh yeah no
that's definitely a bruise oh what the fuck did she fall did
she hit her head bro okay we need to take you to the doctors
if anything oh my god i have enough beds for everybody oh
yeah i do too sick okay i have oh my god might not buy any
more med kits god damn it I gotta buy more med kits.
Alright, it's fine.
Yeah, she definitely hits something on the way, so I'll send
you.
I'll send you over.
Do they even do anything for me?
Alright, go in there.
Alright.
Last one.
Last one for the day.
What's the point of all this?
We're all dead already.
Whoa.
This is the healthiest one I've seen this.
it oh she hiccuped oh wait 163 or 42 43 okay okay tell me 43
163 yeah
Tell me, yeah, definitely the healthiest cast.
For sure.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, she did say what was the point.
You know what, girl?
Today's your lucky day.
Thanks for at least letting me live.
Yeah.
No problem.
Yep.
That's me.
We're all dead already.
I'm speak for yourself, sweetie.
Petra said that you was super chat.
Thank you.
Another good day of work.
For a donkey bird.
How could you live with yourself?
having a, uh, I'm having a great time.
I got paid for doing my job.
Damn it.
They got damp.
What?
What do you mean told me?
Um, I had to resupply and then check the quarantine and then
do and speed the TSA and then make sure everybody is
healthy.
What do you mean?
I also have to make sure the fucking We put a lid on the
power.
Oh, okay.
The generator consumes fuel.
Be careful.
Mindful of each building consumes power.
An upgraded building will consume more power.
Exceeding generator power.
Alright.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I will just...
What?
Say the magic words.
Now move on.
Alright.
be light right did I do it oh it's right here wait what how
do I restart it
do I have to like walk there oh my god give me I gotta
fucking walk there too oh my Oh, hey, crazy, Dave.
Okay, there you go.
Let that be live!
Yep, that's me.
You may be asking how...
Here's a lock on this situation.
Well, I'll start it, man.
That means more bodies and more pressure.
Don't let any straw break the camel's back.
Okay, I have to upgrade the base.
This is a lot smaller than I expected.
Alright.
Upgrade to level 2.
upgrades.
Increasing the checkpoint levels, unlocks new tools and
upgrades, new tool upgrades, and building upgrades.
You would need these upgrades to detect new symptoms more
easily and meet the demands for evacuation.
Alright?
Tablet time.
Uh, upgrades.
Okay, we gotta grab this.
Improve.
Bam.
But not so fast.
Now we need to deal with the generator.
Huh?
What about the generator?
Return the base mode.
But that's all my money.
But...
But I saved...
I worked so hard saving all that money.
Don't get caught, soldier.
Everything in this camp requires power.
It's more power.
It worked so hard!
Time to pay up.
Time to pay your taxes.
all right oh my god all my money okay uh we have six nobody
is sick all right that's good we gotta buy more food though
sadly oh my god i'm so poor wait where's the canteen Okay,
how much is one?
$60 per person?
That just better be a mission than Mia for each goddamn
survivor.
This is what I'm saying.
I don't want more survivors.
I met the quota already.
I met the government quota.
See this?
It's usually used to test reflexes.
The infected have slowed reactions.
You'll notice the difference right away.
Bro, like, bro, where's my instant ramen?
Personally, I'd like to see a bat wrapped in barbed wire.
Eh, whatever.
Just be careful.
Don't go crack at any skulls.
Alright.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Don't remember to not hit come in the head or torso.
Alright, let's check on them.
Verified.
Quarantine status.
No incidents reported.
Give me a second.
This is all too much.
Well, I guess you can...
Oh, she just only has yellow eyes.
So...
You know what?
Wait.
Is she react?
That's reacting, right?
She...
She's reacting, right?
I
think she's fine, right?
She just has yellow.
Yellow.
Oh, shit.
Oh, cross reflex.
Oh, if she attacks me, no self-defense is allowed.
Self-defense is not allowed here.
I thought it was just yellow eyes.
I just noticed.
that i got that wrong then she should be fine right 36 and
36 118 oh yeah yo you can go now yeah that looks fine go to
that survivor block wonder if i'll know anybody in there all
right your turn did you get better we didn't give you any
medication but like i assume like you know you could have
got wait your freckles are gone or is that you were you the
one with freckles 166 oh
yeah i can whack you oh yep no self-defense oh you never had
freckles
No, go back in there.
I don't trust you.
Yeah, I don't trust.
Get back in there.
You gotta be kidding me.
Alright, your turn.
How about you?
Oh, oh.
Sneezing time.
Still has Freckles.
Oh.
Has reflexes.
3-6, 37, 38.
39, 40, 41, 42, 43.
Luckily, I hope it's not airborne.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure you'll be able to have plenty.
You'll be able to rest for a very, very long time.
Very safe.
We have a 100% success rate there.
Give this man some water.
Alright.
First test.
Oh!
Yeah?
You want to explain that?
Alright.
Well.
Yeah, you want to explain that?
to me girl she's not even looking me in the eye i am a
contract oh not even i am a government employee shouldn't we
be wearing ppe mega thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you um i am a government employee
thing is that oh That's just it.
There's nothing else.
So it's like Everything I guess I'll send her to quarantine
No, no you don't understand.
All right next person Don't bother checking there's nothing
valuable left
Oh Damn Yeah, well good news is you have absent reflex There
is one bad news, though.
But I'll tell you that in the building next door.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I have two bad news.
But I'll tell you that in the building next door.
Wait, what was this?
Okay, you know what?
Well, the other one's not as bad.
the other one luckily the other one is not as bad it's like
it's not as bad as i thought there's just the second bad
news is pretty bad but like i said i'll let you know in this
building i'm so tired of this i'll let you know over there
all right absent no bite marks though oh oh what's this
what's this raise your shirt oh God damn it.
I hate that because, like, I'd have to ask for the consent.
I can't just, like, you know, look under that arm sleeve.
I'm trying to save new, new Doki Lan.
He just has, like, no reflexes.
Boy, is that where I hit him?
Oh, maybe that is.
No, because this one's fine.
116.
Was that okay?
Yeah, that's all right
He looks clean.
He just has shitty reflexes.
That's really it All right Head over there poor inspection.
Oh No, wait did I fuck up?
Stay calm and wait for your turn remove your outer clothing
has glasses and gloves Oh
oh did he hide a bite mark oh no oh no is this man me i'm
going back i'm going back oh no i can't even where is he oh
no i swear to god if he hit a bite mark on his goddamn ankle
i swear I swear to God.
I swear to God, if you're fucking hiding,
I don't understand.
Everything seems fine.
No take, seat, back seat.
Live with your mistake.
Okay, I have three more to go.
Oh, he is sneezing.
Oh, wait, slack jaw.
Didn't they say slack jaw was a sign?
Oh, shit.
Alright.
He is aggressive.
Was a sign of zombies or, like, just that they're sick?
Oh, never mind.
Zombie.
Okay.
Alright.
oh yeah mega zombie oh wait is there gonna go are we gonna
get double whammy 41 180 all right mega zombie oh yeah it
hit 41 right oh oh oh oh oh triple whammy okay we got we got
triple whammy here all right just to be sure you have any
skin cuts and bruises as well all right let's see uh i don't
think that's just part of his skin all right all right let's
go off you go the next survivor please i feel okay i promise
okay so is slack jawed like mega zombie or just
Wait, we're talking about him?
Yeah, I know.
I know he's a zombie.
I marked it.
Yeah, I already marked the bite.
That's why I was like, oh, man, I have some bad news.
Step by step.
Does a zombie tell you to wear that, too?
Alright, no.
So what is...
What's like, Slashjohn?
What?
So was, like, Slackjawed, like, zombie, or what?
Because, uh...
She's just...
Bruises.
91.
No, I remember he said something, like, oh, Slackjawed means
something.
Means, like, zombie, or, like...
Or, I don't remember if it was, like, zombie or...
Or...
Or, uh...
Sick.
Or it could be zombie.
Yeah, but they said something about Slackjaw.
I don't remember what it was.
Oh, it means I have... Oh, Slackjaw means I have to check
for reflexes.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, she could have had a stroke, you know?
She could have had a stroke, guys.
She's old.
it's very stressful during the apocalypse I don't guys know
this but this apocalypse is pretty fucking stressful okay
well I think it's fine doesn't have any of the bad stuff
like you know like she doesn't have any cuts right yeah None
of the bad stuff.
She only has, like, the...
You know...
She's just old.
That's all.
I'm going to test it.
She just has that...
See?
She's just old.
Oh, that is my hammer.
I think it's fine.
Alright, off to the...
Goodbye.
I am.
I am a hero.
Oh my god, a lot A lot of people have Oh Bro, what the fuck?
Everybody's having a stroke these days During the zombie
apocalypse Okay, that's my hammer Oh man I have to like
upgrade my I have too many people now Living here Guys This
sucks
all right i have nine food oh i went beyond my quota yeah i
still have to take care of all these people all right 116 i
just forget like temperature wise or like pulse wise okay
under 16 um tm welcome to tomato farm welcome I feel like
they could sleep on the floor.
It should be fine.
This lady has to be like the peak model survivor.
The only thing wrong with her is that she might have...
She has no reflexes.
Actually, no, never mind.
I think that's pretty bad.
I think you have to have reflexes and reaction time to
survive.
Okay, the only issue is that she might have had a stroke.
But other than that, she's...
a perfect survivor all right that's really it that's just
one tiny problem point poor inspection oh no oh no oh that's
bad Why do none of them have any reflexes?
Oh, no.
What happened?
I checked everything.
What do you mean?
Poor inspection.
36.
91.
Yeah, that's that thing.
96 91 yeah there's nothing here yeah no she's fucking yeah
no there's nothing else here
no this is not a reaction look at this this guy is a fucking
wall
at least like i can send this guy to quarantine i don't how
can i have a better inspection oh man let's hope um let's
hope my people are alive tomorrow honestly let's let's let's
let the two people I sent in that said poor inspection
doesn't end up fucking me over surely it's fine right
what she
was my bottom oh my god he's this guy this guy spent his
time in quarantine just to be bit
my bottom survivor
it's okay less mouths to feed guys it's okay it's okay less
mouths to feed yippee
All right, this is why we have extra people.
Just in case I made a little oopsie like today.
Identification verified.
Quarantine status stable.
No incidents reported.
Yeah, no incidents reported, guys.
Not at all.
What's the point of all this?
We're all dead already.
Wait, new.
36, 148.
What did I mark you as?
Oh, you're no longer...
Oh, you're still elevated, though.
Yeah, you're still elevated.
Alright, let's...
Alright, let's check you.
Quarantine, recheck.
What was wrong with you?
Oh, your eyes are better now.
Alright, nice.
We fixed it.
all right okay let's try this again okay um absent reflex
you're safe all right guys it's okay thanks for letting me
live at least that should be fine right all right it's fine
We still have six people.
Alright, what was wrong with you?
You were very mean to me.
Alright, did you learn your lesson?
Oh, there we go.
You learned... Alright, nice.
Alright, you learned your lesson.
I remember you.
You were a very mean lady.
Alright, now I need to.
I think that's fine, right?
Yeah, alright.
She was just really mean to me.
realize that if you're mean to me you get sent to the you
get sent to the box mean lady learn her lesson when do i oh
this is the last day all right okay
just no reflexes this time all right
Gotta be sure.
It's gotta be sure.
I wasn't very sure last time.
130.
What was 130 again?
I always freak.
Oh wait, elevated pulse.
He has have...
Luckily, luckily I have two more spots left in the
quarantine zone so this is okay i'm not like missing stuff
my kids made it through yesterday i just need to join them i
do not have children in this quarantine like are you doing
this for like pity i know for sure there's no kids here okay
he has reflexes he does have yellow eyes but apparently
that's okay yeah bro is lying there is no children in my new
new doky line yeah no crazy david's still alive luckily it
was not one of the guys that got infected he is hiccuping
though which we don't like have i checked his pulse yet oh
guys i don't i definitely think i didn't check his pulse
okay um let me double check Oh, yeah, no, now I've checked
your post.
Just to be sure.
Oh, well then, we're going to let you see your kids.
Wait, who's that?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this guy?
Which YouTuber are you?
Hey, buddy.
Don't worry, I'm not sick.
I just look like this.
Wait, who the fuck is this guy?
um you are in a quarantine zone stay calm and wait for your
turn remove your outer clothing um i hate to break it to you
but i don't think you're a skeleton you um Can you even not
I hate breaking to you buddy, but you might not just be a
skeleton no more Are you gonna kill the dev then we'll
finally be freed?
Oh, man, brother He's not a zombie yet No pipe marks he's
good is so a lot.
Just quarantine.
Sorry, I didn't feel comfortable beating my Oshi.
Hispanic.
Thank you.
Let's see what chat.
Oh, this is pretty awkward.
I mean, we could, we could, you know, maybe I gotta double
check, you know.
Oh.
Maybe it's just an arm thing.
Let's double check the...
Oh.
Oh,
shit, he knows.
Bro, I thought we cool.
Okay, yeah, she has reflexes.
Okay, those are just me.
Is that a...
No, she's...
She's just dirty.
And that's just me hitting her arm.
I swear to God if I miss a hidden bite mark.
Like, bro, that's not cool, bro.
I thought we cool.
I thought we chill like that, bro.
There he says.
Well, she seems very healthy.
Like, she seems like the model citizen.
But the last time I said that.
Okay.
No cuts or bruises.
Nope.
Don't see any cuts nor bruises here.
I'm looking everywhere.
Well, this time, guys.
This time, she is a model survivor.
She has no freckles, no bruises, no cuts, no bite marks.
Her eyes seem okay.
Her reflexes are gray.
And she is not sick whatsoever.
Just to be sure.
Yep.
Just right.
Now she should be okay.
Yeah, excellent inspection.
I knew it was excellent.
I think I need to buy more food again.
Oh, I'm so broke.
I'm not okay.
I...
Oh, I need more food.
Where is the food?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, no.
need one more oh no I'm not I'm so broke all right hammer
all right you're a mean lady I hope there is a bite mark on
you she's just dirty and mean all right well we know what to
do wait double check We're just a very mean lady.
Alright, yep, she's just hyper-aggressive.
Alright, get in that quarantine.
What do you mean why you hit me?
Oh!
Oh my god, that...
Thank you for at least not yelling at me.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
I thought I was like, zombie!
Oh my god.
I thought that was a zombie.
That actually jump scared me.
Okay, bruise.
Security jump scared.
Legitimately thought I was a zombie right there.
A poorly geared zombie.
136.
Well, she seems fine.
She just has a little bruise there.
Is that cut, too?
No.
She's just a little bruise Yeah, she invaded my personal
space guys All right, no hidden cuts underneath the hair
Cold I think that's it bruises are fine all right corn go go
have fun All right next survivor What are you doing is this
really necessary Okay, that's not a bite mark you're fine i
had oh oh oh you might need a new shirt though i mean she's
just bloody it's not a bite mark she doesn't i don't even
know these are cuts are these cuts or like whose blood is
that yeah but whose blood is it reflexes seem good all right
is that bruise Or she's just yellow.
I don't know about her.
Her pulses seem fine.
But like...
I can't tell these are cuts or not.
Like, are those from herself or like someone else?
Oh my gosh, already got how she turns.
Serena, God.
I'm double checking if there's butts.
I don't have enough space in quarantine, though.
It's full.
I can't tell.
Like, I need her to take a shower.
How am I supposed to give a proper examination if, like,
that's just blood?
Like, oh, man.
I don't know.
Is she...
Like, I can't like that's just that's not bruise she's just
yellow over there like her neck is just yellow for some
reason uh
like is that your blood or not lady this would help me so
much if you could let me know if this blood is yours or not
like that would be so helpful right now
She had to kill to get here.
Let her in.
She worked so hard to get here.
No, it's not a cut.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean, it's not.
Is that a bite?
But that is so hard to see.
It doesn't look like a bite.
I can't check them out.
They're not healed yet.
They're still fucked up.
Yeah, I can't tell.
There's no cuts on her, except for, like, there's no cuts on
her, actually.
Alright, let's check the quarantine real quick.
It's him that I put in.
He's been in there for two days.
And I don't know if I can trust it.
Oh my god, this one is hard.
I can't tell if it's dried blood or like a bite It's like
the bite the blood is really hiding it really good.
That's smart I just don't have extra water I think she's
fine.
Alright, let's check we're yoloing it Oh Oh, she's fine.
She's fine.
Okay, nice.
Yolo works.
Okay.
Yeah I passed Okay, who was your officer?
Okay, so I could maybe fire him I might oh 40 41 for it okay
for it I might I just need to ask who was the who was the
officer so I could like you know speak to him real quick
like i mean just oh my god oh my god this is like deep into
the infection too like girl you're you are not the chosen
one you are not the main character uh she's optimistic all
right let me check all right do you have any other Anything
else to show me before I put in my paperwork?
Bingo, he got bingo.
Yeah, don't worry.
Oh, wait, this one.
Sorry, cross-reflex.
We have bingo.
Where am I going?
Alright.
Please don't scan me with that.
They've heard stories.
What, my hammer?
Yeah, don't worry, it's scanning?
Oh, okay.
Let's see, very mean.
Is it just yellow or is it...
Wait, is that yellow eyes or...
Or...
No, it's yellow eyes.
Okay, yellow eyes.
Alright, why don't you want me to scan you?
Oh, 38.
167.
Hmm.
Ooh.
I mean, if you have a fever, you just...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
This is bad.
Oh.
Identification verified.
Quarantine status stable.
No incidents reported.
This guy?
Do you want me to release him?
Let's just get this over with.
But his pulse is so high.
He's just...
I swear to God.
If I lose my money, I swear to God.
Maybe he's just really stressed out.
I swear to God, guys.
If I lose my money because...
I do have 12 survivors.
So, like, at best he'll just kill three.
Like, at best.
Oh my god, everybody's sick.
You're gonna kill Crazy Dave.
No!
Crazy Dave!
That's okay, Crazy Dave is too crazy.
He'll live.
Alright.
Beds don't grow on trees here, soldier.
Can't keep people in the survivors block forever.
Evacuate.
Oh, okay.
Let's go.
Let's move them out.
All right, we got, we got, we hit the quota.
Start evacuation now.
Survivors cannot stay.
The science mission need all the help they can get.
Go to a science game where we select survivors to go to the
military for extra cash.
Remember your quota.
If you don't have enough survivors sent out, you are
jeopardizing the official mission.
Uh.
Okay.
money we gotta keep crazy Dave we gotta keep crazy Dave
science money science Money, science, money, science.
Money, science.
Yeah, but then I could get money and science.
And then, money.
Wait.
Money.
Yay!
And evacuation.
Crazy Dave, you live here forever.
I hope it went smoothly.
The report will come tomorrow morning.
Yeah, I got my quota.
Yippee!
Oh, you're right.
Less people to feed.
Okay, maintenance.
Yeah!
Oh my god, so much money!
And zero deaths!
Okay.
Nice work, buddy.
Remember, quotas are our main mission.
If we failed them a couple of times, and let's just say they
won't be sending us to quarantine.
Anyway, we've got lots of work in us.
What's that?
Come see me.
Okay.
What is it?
What is that?
Oh All right, we all signed a consent form, right?
This is fine guys.
This is fine.
They all signed a consent form guys
Guys they all they all signed a consent form guys All right,
did you learn your lesson?
Okay, well
They signed she signed a consent form.
Whoa nice panties
All right, I gotta make sure she's not hiding a goddamn bite
mark on me All right, let's see 100 and now
Oh my okay, okay it didn't go to 41 It did guys it at It
didn't go to Fortin.
So, um...
At least it seems to have more guards.
Well, um...
Yeah.
Well, I hope you...
You know, because you did such a great job in quarantine,
uh, I'm gonna send you to a special place.
I don't...
I'm clear.
Alright, what was wrong with you?
Also, did this shooter?
Oh, yep, infected eliminated.
Alright, gotta make sure they shot her.
Alright, how about...
you did you learn your lesson are you you saw what the fuck
why is she green what what infected
oh yeah no i i assume necrosis is infection right there all
right how about you oh you learned your lesson all right
that's good to know all right well now that she has learned
her lesson and know that no knew what happened to the other
girl thank you can't just ask people why they agree is she
gone yet i need to check on this guy all right what was
wrong with you again sober with it okay you're not green at
least but you are elevated all right surely that's fixed now
right 174 that's i keep forgetting i don't know why oh i
mean you barely you made it you made the cut just to be sure
because you did sign a consent form whoa all right Just to
be sure.
That you ain't hiding nothing from me.
You know, I'm just double checking for new new Doki Lan.
I'm doing this for new new Doki Lan.
I get back in there.
Alright, are there any green people?
One's just real.
pale because i guess he's not all right no green people all
right get over here oh you're you thought this is all too
much you think hiding behind clothes is gonna help you
that's right i feel like this like probably is gonna give
her radiation poisoning but like or the or the safe haven
you know she seems fine.
I don't see no bite marks.
I don't know.
Now I'm paranoid.
Now, guys, I'm just making sure there's no bite marks, guys.
I am very...
I'm just... Her ass is flat, though.
Okay.
Those are... Oh, my God.
That is a fucked up bruise, though.
I will have to say.
Back of her leg?
That's not nothing.
It's just...
Nah, there's nothing there.
It's just her really fucked up bruise.
Uh, yeah, that, no, that's just a, that's just a red bruise.
It could potentially mean infected, though.
It does say that.
Well, just to make sure.
Now she's fine there.
She just has an elevated pulse.
Alright.
Elevated pulse.
Good reflexes.
And, I guess that's it.
I don't think she has any cussing.
or bruises when i did the examination i mean she okay no she
has a john ass bruise here but other than that other than
that i just have to quarantine her all right get in there
all right he's pale oh oh look into my eyes oh no reflex all
right absent reflex yellow eyes Oh, wait.
Pell skin.
Potentially infected.
Oops, sorry.
I was trying to scan.
Holy shit.
Oh, did a fucking cinder block fell on?
Bro, what the fuck?
There's so many problems, man.
I do think...
Oh, hey, grippers.
I do think this man might need to see a doctor.
But, like...
but like I cannot really do much about sorry buddy you have
a lot of things wrong with you and I know you really want to
see a doctor right now but like oh I just oh man I guess
I'll take you to quarantine all right come on can I just go
you here like like um like i don't i don't know maybe you
think we'll chop uh that's necrosis oh oh your eyes all
right all right there's that too all right um a plus for
Confidence, though.
Let me see if I can find the bite mark.
I assume that's where the bite mark is.
I assume that's where it is, and it's just progressed
progressed more and more.
Because, like, oh my god, I don't know.
Maybe she's blind?
Maybe, maybe she was blind.
It could be worse.
It could be, you're right, it could be worse.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
Girl.
You need a doctor right now.
Oh, my God.
How many fingers am I holding?
I'm just going to do the scan first, just in case.
Just in case I see a giant-ass bite mark in my face.
Glasses and gloves.
holy wait is that necrosis oh let me double check where did
that where did i found oh i mean i gotta get some bonus
points if you're sick too oh hey bonus points
I mean, it could be a huge birthmark.
You're right.
Well, goodbye.
Yeah, we're just going to cut your leg off.
This is just a bad dream.
Don't worry.
That's where our doctors are.
That is...
What?
Question mark?
Also, I don't know.
they like know I'm going to bring out a goddamn x-ray I just
run oh my god he's so thick that like it's so hard to scan
this this man are these blood or cuts I think they're just
blood I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure these are just blood right or it cuts I can't
tell actually let me look up
I cannot tell Well Let's just test these out first Maybe
we'll get lucky I can't tell It looks like No to me it looks
like Blood I guess I could upgrade it Oh okay that's
actually That's actually convenient I'm gonna upgrade this
Okay What?
There we go.
Yeah, they were just blood.
Alright.
It was just blood, guys.
Let's see if the zombie bit his feet.
See if the zombie is a little bit, like, ginky.
Cuts normally have blood around them.
Nope, just regular blood.
You are in a quarantine zone.
Stay calm and wait for your...
Yeah, he seems fine.
Everything seems okay.
I think this guy is the peak model citizen.
Yeah, he looks clean as hell.
Sir, you are.
Have I ever told you you look fly as hell right now?
Actually, you're just perfect.
You have nothing wrong with you.
The peak male physique right here.
You're not even green.
Isn't that great?
I'll be okay, right?
Yeah.
Are you sure?
You're not even green.
My kids just made it through yesterday.
How do they keep telling me their kids are here?
Okay, hurry.
Eyes are yellow.
Yellow eyes.
all right let's see
why is she so bro that's okay I'm just gonna make sure I'm
like a little suspicious because like her face is red as
hell and then like and then she's like super ashy right now
I guess she didn't Use lotion?
She used like...
She...
She just didn't use sunscreen, I guess?
Yeah.
Is that pale?
I can't tell she's pale or just like...
I can't tell.
Pale...
That is not a red bruise.
The red bruise is like really fucked up.
all she is is like she has poor reef oh wait i test her
reflexes i'll make sure again oh yeah i did she just has
shitty reflex her face is red but then the rest of her skin
is like not
this one's hard i don't have enough space in quarantine too
right now
if anything she's just really sick
Is she good?
Stay calm and wait for your turn.
Is that pale skin?
I can't tell if she just doesn't go in the sun.
Like, no, is there actually red skin here?
No.
Oh, wait, there is.
Oh, okay.
Alright, that's new.
I didn't see that.
All their symptoms are just fine.
Alright.
Well, she's just sick, I guess.
I put it in quarantine.
I don't have enough space.
I don't like how he's just standing there.
Yeah.
I mean...
Do we risk it?
Can I upgrade quarantine?
size?
Let me check.
I actually don't know if I have enough money.
Oh, nice.
I do.
Alright.
Lucky for you.
I have enough money.
Yay!
Alright.
We're good.
Clocking out.
Another successful day at work.
I gotta buy more generator.
I gotta max that out.
All right.
Another successful day at work, guys.
Yippee.
Nice.
Job well done for Dokeybird.
The warden of new, new Dokeylaan.
Yeah!
And zero deftion block.
Executed.
Oh, I guess like for like someone that I thought was
infected, but not, you know, check the bulletin board
immediately.
We have more tasks.
Bro, I, please, I don't need another promotion.
Check the bulletin's board immediately.
I'm tasking this will leave notes for you.
Each item has a time limit.
Man, who claims he survives, but our records list him as
dead if he shows up, send him straight to quarantine.
Okay.
Alright, well, I got...
Oh.
Well...
I knew there was something wrong with you, Steve Taylor.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, yeah!
We have more space now!
Yay!
Let's go!
Free reset.
I knew there was something wrong with that man.
I fucking knew it.
Not the one I...
It all worked out!
Guys, it all worked out in the end.
How the hell did he win a 3v1?
Alright.
He was fine.
Good reflexes.
Check, check.
I'm gonna do...
Oh, okay, I thought that there was something wrong.
I thought I was...
like oh my god he's green but it's just his briefs guys
remember to write this down yeah it's gonna be on the test
i'm like the doctor you know like you're the guys are like
the new uh what are they called during like oh my god wait
he's a model citizen too when you shadow the doctor
he looks pretty healthy i mean yeah is it the intern i felt
like doctor apprentice called interns is he solomon oh i
didn't ask his name what's your name a no resident is that a
resident wait what what's the word called for like the
doctors that oh per what residency oh yeah you guys are
doing your residence residency and i'm your teacher doing my
rounds right now so make sure to write this down if you want
permanent residency you want to pass the test guys
I'm the senpai here.
Alright, everything seems fine.
He seems good to go.
I'll double check real quick.
This is my teacher.
I'm not getting the job.
Wait, I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure these zombies aren't kinky.
One day, I swear to God, one day we're gonna find a bite
mark on those toes.
We gotta make sure the zombie ain't a freak.
Yeah, he looks incredibly...
Bro, he's not even dirty.
Like, this man?
Where did you come from?
He literally is like...
He's not fucking...
Like, he found a shower somehow.
And found a way to work out.
Alright.
Excellent inspection.
I've seen this before.
for ten bucks says he's got contraband in that backpack oh a
containing inspected table personal items and food are
prohibited even earn reward or is for contra for
confiscating contraband anyone must be treated as infected
okay believe the things people try to sneak into their new
life take this guy for example a real Weirdo who are what
the fuck this guy's right here find a whole arsenal Can't
let that into the camp.
Wait, what's contraband?
No, he she was just trying to make sushi.
Wait, what what what did they say out he can take?
Handbook baggage Personal items and food.
What's contra what's considered contraband?
Like okay.
Yeah, do you think this?
Gosh, I don't know.
I don't know if this is a personal item or not.
Maybe it's to light up the fish.
Got the sausage.
You know?
Is he to light up the sausage to cook it exactly?
Is that knife considered a weapon?
Or is that just...
Like, that's obviously to cut the fish.
But is that...
What is that an onion?
Is onion not good?
Alright, what about metal?
Because it's confiscating a metal can.
What?
That counts?
It's a pan!
That's a weapon!
Does this count?
But, frying pans, that's what I learned in chicken, winner,
winner, chicken dinner.
In a quarantine zone, stay calm and wait.
What about this?
Remove your outer clothing, hats, glasses, and gloves.
Because they confiscated a fucking soda.
Yeah, but what about the soda can?
It depends on if the game is said in the UK or not.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Lolly.
Oh, alcohol.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, you're fine.
This is fine, then.
Alright, you can keep all that.
It'd be funny if I find a fucking bite after all that shit.
One day.
One day I will find a zombie bite on the toes.
One day I will find a freaky zombie.
A freaky ass on me.
He seems fine.
No bite marks so far.
Wait, what's your name?
Whoops, not that.
Ironed.
Alright.
Fine.
No, he's just wearing yoga pants.
Everything seems okay.
I swear to God, there's a bite mark right in the inside of
your thighs.
Because you are like...
Like you were asking to be bit.
You were...
Yeah, you were...
You were 100% asking to be bit there.
Oh?
He has weapon and back.
Weapon.
Alright.
Let's go.
Grab your items.
All right, let me look at your backpack.
God, this is so elaborate now.
Just cough.
Oh.
Watch out.
Oh, thank you, man.
Oh.
He's Chinese.
He spoke Chinese.
Whoa.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, don't worry, buddy, I didn't,
what the fuck?
A toofer?
All right, okay, buddy.
I swear to you, guys, I found a third, but, oh, how are you
walking?
Wait, maybe he's immune.
Wait, wait, are you Solomon?
Remove your outer clothing.
Has glasses and gloves.
You should...
Wait.
Is this Solomon?
Wait, that could be him.
He got three bites.
One, two, three.
It's just that his name is Chinese.
Is this one?
Oh, wait.
That's a fourth bite.
Uh, they never told me about the fourth fight guy.
Maybe, I don't know this kid.
Maybe it's Solomon in Chinese.
Okay, nobody, oh, bro, nobody told me about the fourth.
I can't even tap this four times.
Guys, I don't know if you saw them in no more.
They said three, not four bites.
Guys, I told you, I can't read Chinese.
I can only speak and listen.
He's got one.
Oh, yeah, he came over here with the four bites.
Three in a row.
Go for one more.
The bites just cancel each other out.
oh my god is it no i didn't no i'm i'm serious though is
this solomon the chinese guys is this i guess i'm actually
serious for anyone that can read chinese just in case if it
is that is so smart
no god damn it well um i'm sorry man you have four fucking
bites like i i am surprised you have no i mean you could be
the most immune you could be the chosen one but it wasn't in
my bulletin board and and a good soldier follows orders oh
yeah i forgot to
He was not happy All right, just gotta be sure.
Oh, yeah, infected limited I gotta be sure I you know it was
very hard to tell because like He did look very healthy for
four fucking bites like
You you gotta admit guys he he take that shit like a fucking
gamer he like a like after the fourth you know after the
third second fight I wouldn't even come here but like you he
really did think he was the main character that must have
been the shittiest infection like the slowest fucking
infection in the world is
this Solomon oh Oh, Solomon!
Wait, you don't even have butts!
I mean, you do have freckles, though, I think.
Those are freckles, right?
Yeah, they are.
Oh, my God, that is him.
Alright, go to quarantine, Solomon.
Alright.
Let me check that bag.
He has...
I've heard stories.
What the fuck is that?
Don't take it.
Oh.
It's all I have left of my mom.
Her blood?
Wait, that's onion!
Whoops.
The onion's in there.
Wait, how is onion contraband, guys?
Or garlic, garlic, garlic.
How is garlic contraband?
is that a drug i need that what the fuck like why okay
that's fucked up because because in here the garlic was
categorized as a contraband like and also a biohazard but
yet for some reason kill her anyway so why would i lose
money for that like if we're gonna kill her anyway i should
not be losing money for for this shit this is your eye it's
just your eyes yellow right okay i don't think she has much
longer to live though to be honest she does not look like oh
the garlic is just there why a garlic
The colic is just to be used for skill.
That's fucking crazy.
Bro, I'm going to put some science points on.
On the range.
I don't like how little range this is.
I'm science-ing.
How much larger is it?
Oh, yeah, there you go.
a lot better.
She doesn't have any cuts.
She's just really fucked up.
What is it?
Oh, red bruise.
Okay, we still have to send you to quarantine.
You're very fucked up.
Alright, next person, please.
Alright.
Competent.
Come on.
Alright, what the fuck did I miss?
No, I gotta know.
What did I... Get over here.
Get over it.
Is it your toes?
I swear to God, if I missed your toes again, I swear to God.
What the fuck did I miss?
Temperature?
Oh, she's fine.
Look.
See?
See, she's fine.
What the fuck did I miss?
Yeah.
Yeah, mark the bag.
What are you supposed to do with infected baggage?
Well, apparently...
Oh, it's because I confiscated her bag.
Oh, yeah.
Now I remember.
It's because I took her mother.
Yeah, it's the items.
I took her mom.
It was literally a vial of zombie blood.
And then they were like, Dodge Bad.
Like...
it like it would tell me wouldn't it tell me if it's like a
bio has like that I claimed a bio hazard all right I'm
grabbing that gun I'm grabbing this high school and I'm
grabbing that you can keep everything else oh well I guess I
gotta liquidate you.
I thought you could confiscate you.
You're supposed to confiscate it too.
Alright, get over here.
You had your mom.
Please don't scan me with that.
Oh, don't worry.
Apparently this it says body parts.
Oh.
They don't have to know.
Oh, does the blood not count?
Do not touch.
I didn't touch it, I swear.
I swear I didn't touch the blood.
I swear I didn't touch it.
Oh wait, that's a tattoo.
Oh yeah, I did this already.
Oh, she is red, a little red.
Oh, yep, okay.
In fact, they eliminated.
Alright, I was gonna say, like, I forgot, I didn't realize I
was not supposed to touch the blood.
I was just like, what's this?
I'm just like, whoa, what's this over there?
No, there's no bite mark on the tattoo.
That would be very cheeky, though.
Oh, that's a bruise, though.
Right there.
Alright, you are red.
You have a bruise.
But other than that, you seem pretty okay.
Yep.
Yep, everything seems fine.
Yeah, it's like, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, I almost
forgot.
One day, one day I will find that kinky zombie.
I want to make sure it's in between the thighs, too.
All right, you seem safe.
Other than the fact that you brought a weapon, but that's
not illegal.
It's just, you know, gotta take it.
All right, Emily.
Everything okay with Emily?
Yay!
Excellent inspection!
When will I find the green man?
Are you green?
Wait, what?
You're not green.
I'm just waiting until I find to get the green man.
Okay, hiccups.
Oh, shit.
Sick tattoos, though, bro.
Those are some sick-ass tattoos.
Alright, bruises.
You got really fucked up, bro, though.
But don't worry, Nunu Doki-Lan.
You're gonna live like a king here.
Other than that, it's fine.
You just have really bad bruises.
Oh, wait, two really bad bruises, actually, right?
It was a yellow one somewhere.
Is that you with the yellow one?
Or was that fucking dreaming?
yeah no it's just a regular all right don't never forget the
toes all right wait is that yellow eyes oh yeah yellow eyes
thanks for reminding me about that what else hey you
don't have a fever at least
you you don't have a fever there's some little things oh hey
your bag oh shit all right how did that gun get in there oh
i wonder how planted it on me oh you mean the grenade and
like shotgun shells yeah um all right well fool this is
awkward but you are a little sick so we're gonna have to put
you in the quarantine zone.
Don't worry.
Just remember to take your right from there and don't mind
these securities.
Just, you know, it is the quarantine zone.
So we just gotta be careful.
You know?
There?
Yep.
I heard that correctly.
That there.
Right there.
Don't make me wait.
All right.
Nice.
Successfully quarantined.
Oh, chicken nuggets.
An organic rice.
damn that's a nice fish okay um you almost you you all you
know it almost covered it up
well at least i get more food in the well you know the good
thing is new dokey don't gets more free food
all right you know you could have wore a glove i mean it's
not gonna help you But, you know, we could have tried a
little harder.
It's just a little bit harder.
You know?
Doesn't hurt.
Doesn't hurt to...
Oh, well...
Bye.
We're gonna...
Huh?
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna say, why is she not, why is she still
standing there?
Alright.
Another job well done.
Time to clock out.
Wait, do I need to do anything for the base?
Just to be sure.
Is everybody happy?
Huh?
Are you all happy right now?
Let's see.
15 people.
Upgrades.
Passively.
Oh!
Yeah, fuck that.
Yeah.
Free food, so I don't have to buy food?
Okay, 25 people.
I don't need to buy that yet.
Metal detector.
Okay, I can just check the item myself.
I do not need to upgrade that.
That's fine.
I'm a gamer.
All right, here we go.
I'll buy food later.
I'll buy food tomorrow.
Tomorrow, like, there's no discount if I buy it.
It's not Costco or nothing.
What are the storylines?
That's what made paper please.
This is the storyline.
Don't worry.
Right here.
We're in it now.
A few, few times.
And also crazy Dave.
Oh my god, I fucked up.
Oh no.
That's okay, it's okay.
We got the bomb.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, the trash is the last measure.
Alright, we're fine.
Okay, wave two.
Okay, it might say wave two.
but we are very fine.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It says wave two, but we're so healthy.
We are so healthy.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
I told you.
One last guy.
Look at that.
Wall secured.
Amazing story.
selling.
That's the story.
Pew pew.
Alright.
Not zero deaths.
Economy.
Purchases.
Penalties.
Oh.
Ronville.
I mean it's $300.
I'm fucking.
It's fine.
It balances out.
Soldiers say some jackass wrote dirty poems on the camp
walls.
Find out who they're talking about.
And track down the artist.
Oh.
So I'm intentionally a zombie into last.
He was beaten severely before.
We believe he'll attempt to gain access.
Do not let him in.
Bruised face.
What do I... Oh, Target eliminated.
How would I know?
He just has a bruised face.
But like... Wait, what?
Oh, there's Solomon.
Find all the poems using a flashlight.
What does it look like?
Wait, what do the poems look like?
How the fuck am I supposed to know what the poems look like?
They got him.
I just find newspapers.
Oh, hey, crazy, Dave.
It looks like a poem.
Alright, whatever.
We're just gonna go call in the next survivor.
Oh, my home?
Would it be in here?
Would it actually?
I don't even know where it would be.
I have no idea what that would look like.
Alright, fuck it.
Let's just call in the next survivor.
Bring him in.
It just looks like words.
All I see are newspapers.
Alright, fuck it.
Bring him in.
Why did it lock the corn?
I sent like three people in there.
Huh?
That symptom's not in our database.
A fresh mutation.
Deja vu.
Pandemics never change.
Maybe he's going through puberty.
Time to add it to the symptom chart.
Oh.
What does that mean?
Tap the right symptom on the list.
Now switch over to the distribution tab.
There's a lot we don't understand about the disease.
Scientific research can give us some clues.
Data from the lab.
Doesn't know how to swim.
Alright.
Oh.
The poor guy won't make it through the procedure.
You saw him, right?
Even a light breeze would knock him over.
This way, maybe his sacrifice will actually help keep others
alive somehow.
Oh, there was a poem on the wall of my home?
Oh, really?
Here?
I don't see no poem.
Or is it in here?
How the fuck is this poem?
It's a graffiti.
Oh, wait, it's a graffiti.
Oh, wait, yeah.
Oh, here you go.
Oh!
Yeah, I remember it said graffiti, but I was, like, a little
confused.
Alright, I found it.
What?
Was that always there?
Was the red markings on the floor always there, guys?
Street.
I imagine that was also...
I wonder if there's more here.
Where the fuck is the next poem?
I mean, street is not the...
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, it is like a little hint.
Okay, let's try.
Laboratory.
There has to be one here.
Hey, guys.
Just got trying to find my local graffiti.
Oh.
Where is it?
What the fuck is it?
Oh, my God.
He climbed up here.
He's just sending me on a wild goddamn goose chase.
Oh, hey.
Alright.
Oregon highlighted destroy the organs highlighted yellow and
as they are blocking the way to target Oregon do not destroy
organs highlighted red oh let's go it's trauma center time
I'm pretty good at
that okay all right oops
I think it was the wrong organ guy
attempts to leave the zone without authorization oh he might
have died i just said i just took his ass oh no can i
what a good what a nice day Woo
What do you mean he died for nothing nothing?
What do you mean guys?
I just started my day Just I just started my day guys How is
that noise that's dead?
Oh, it's like Trauma Center!
Oh, we have to just...
Oh, that's cool.
There's like, it's...
He's just hit puberty or some shit.
Oh, that's cool.
You're trying to figure out what his new mutation is.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, we had to go here for something.
I wonder what we had to do again.
It's like deja vu.
That's cool.
I wonder what we have to do inside there.
Destroy the organs.
Highlight a yell and they're blocking the way to the...
How do I destroy it?
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Jesus Christ, this entire thing is blocking it.
Alright, he doesn't need the ribcage.
It's fine.
He doesn't need this.
Alright, he doesn't need his ribs as well.
And then...
You know what?
Who needs that?
You don't need this.
You're fine.
You don't need that.
You don't need this.
Have you ever told you don't need all those ribs?
What is that?
Your gallbladder?
You're fine without it.
Yay!
We did it!
All right, place to extract it.
All right, I discovered a new symptom.
All right.
We did it, guys.
Oh.
Boop.
Operation.
Oh, what do I put in here?
Analyze.
All right, skin rash.
Okay, and then that leads to necrosis.
Okay, all right, that ain't too bad.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
We did it.
First try.
We did the science thing.
And we first tried it, too.
Oh my gosh, we're so smart.
We're so smart, guys.
Alright, we can do the graffiti later.
Alright.
Now it goes through the quarantine.
Oh, now I can.
What am I supposed to do with Solomon?
Is he just chilling here?
Alright, apparently he said he survived.
I don't even know what.
Did he even have any symptoms?
Oh, yeah.
He just has freckles.
What the fuck?
This buddy just has freckles.
I guess do I keep him here?
Just check again.
Alright, next.
Alright, what do you have for me?
Thank you for at least not yelling at me.
What the fuck?
Are these loot boxes?
Ooh.
Which loot boxes do I take?
Alright.
Ooh, loot box time.
Gamba, Gamba.
Biggest one.
It's big.
So there must be lots of stuff in here.
What?
I can't even...
Oh my gosh.
I can't even confiscate it.
What's the point?
I'm not even...
Oh, wait, am I?
Oh!
Wait, X-Ray?
No.
I can't believe it's considered a personal item.
That's messed up.
He seems fine.
He's actually pretty healthy.
Not gonna lie.
There's, like, nothing wrong with him other than the fact
that he has loot boxes.
He cheated the system.
If he puts him...
puts it in a box.
I can't take anything from him.
Oh, this is bullshit.
Open the box.
It's not fair.
Why is it unknown symptom?
Oh, if he has an unknown symptom.
Yeah.
What's in the box?
I can't do anything with this guy.
Maybe you should grab the green one.
I can't even open any of them.
It's not fair.
I swear to God.
Okay.
It's actually...
What
are you doing?
Is this really necessary?
It's just like what's in the...
You need to let me keep that.
What the fuck is that?
Is that a rock or what is that?
Oh my god.
A new gaming PC.
Let's go.
How the fuck did he put Keptat in the bag?
Is that careful he will attack you?
Maybe.
Alright.
Okay.
I mean, sick task.
too, though.
At least, yeah.
Wait, oh, yeah, I forgot about the sword.
Bro is scheming until he dies.
He won't need the setup anyway.
I think he intentionally got bit.
Like, how do you get bit on the fucking forehead?
Bro.
I don't even think I need to scan nothing.
At least, I mean, at least he doesn't have a fever.
At least.
Like, it's little things.
Alright, that is...
I think he has a bite mark.
Corruption's only bad if you're not involved.
Get his rat.
Guys, I'm pretty sure he's not getting his PC back, guys.
I'm pretty sure.
I have a feeling that his PC is not coming with him.
Am I?
Am I in trouble?
I thought I was safe.
Please don't scan me with that.
It is a weird story.
Okay, I'm pretty sure she's yellow for real.
Also, her eyes are red.
Wait, why?
Why are you yellow?
That's yellow, right?
That's green?
Is that green?
That's yellow!
She's yellow!
Yeah, but I have to send her to liquidation anyway.
Yeah!
Like, it doesn't matter.
She's going to liquidation.
No matter what.
Oh, and she has a fever, too.
Oh, 40.
41.
42.
43.
Jesus.
It didn't stop.
43 okay and then I mean I guess just to be safe just to make
sure that I'm you know that you're not as if you are a
zombie or not next thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you you just I just gotta be sure you know maybe she
could be not a zombie
wait do you have necrosis on your fucking neck holy shit
pick a lane like i know you're a zombie already but damn all
right now i'm just gonna i'm gonna send her to the it's fine
i'm sending her to i'm pretty sure i'll find someone else
that's awesome yeah see look she's not yellow here oh and
she won a pie eating contest good for her Now I'm destroying
this.
It's fine.
Guys, I can find another person whose skin is yellow.
One, two, three.
One, two, three, four.
I'm fucking...
Oh, my...
What the fuck?
What was going on?
Oh my god!
And...
Okay, alright.
This lady has a problem.
These...
I think...
I think she might have been...
Okay.
That's...
Alright, she...
She's freaky.
No, she's freaky.
Not the zombie.
She and the zombies were freaky.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, a 50.
The zombies are, this lady's a freak.
This lady is a fucking freak.
And how is she alive?
bro she a freak for real bro she's here for it she's in it
for she's from the streets oh my god i knew it guys i trust
you guys i fucking knew we were gonna find one she had the
lab oh there we go i told you guys
Oh, she's just...
Okay, I think she's a zombie anyway.
I don't think it matters.
I mean, she has freckles, too.
I'm just gonna liquidate her.
Yeah, it's already too late for her.
I fucking... Bro, I knew we were gonna find a zombie.
A freaky zombie, but I did not realize I will find a freaky
survivor instead.
Wait, was she...
Oh yeah, no, she fucked.
Alright, temperature.
Her pulse.
Alright, liquidation.
Get out of here.
She dead anyway.
Don't worry, we'll find someone else.
Guys, you don't understand.
I get paid for liquidation.
This is very important.
What is this?
that oh wait alcohol though what that's alcohol that's a
contraband okay but what is this though i knew it i knew it
i fucking knew it
132 i fucking knew it i can't believe i'm not allowed wait
what did i take yeah
Well, doesn't even matter, anyway.
What was the thing that I took that I didn't...
Yeah, it was alcohol!
There's no way.
Also, you're fucked anyway, buddy.
You're fucked anyway.
You thought you could hide?
Wait, where is it?
Okay, you're not...
You should have wore long pants today, bro.
It's over for you.
I mean, just to be...
Just to be sure.
Wait, where's my hat?
Hammer.
I mean, he's dead anyway.
Oh!
Okay, that's fine.
I thought I'd get punished for that, but it's okay.
Everything is fine.
Oh, I forgot to talk about the baggage, but that's fine.
He's gonna die anyway.
Alright, nice.
Why is he...
Ooh, he has a lot.
Oh, that's an unknown symptom.
Right there.
Alright, let's see.
Bruises.
He angie.
Yeah, he angie, angie.
Alright, unknown symptom.
Lab time.
Alright, George.
Well, I have to.
I mean, it's poor only because I knew what I needed to find.
Alright, buddy.
It's time.
We're gonna...
We're gonna take you to a special place.
Don't worry.
You'll be safe.
Oh, is that...
Oh.
Yeah, but look.
I get to...
I get to take his kidneys, though.
Guys, I get to...
Look, guys.
I got the tickest kidneys.
Boop.
Yay!
I mean, technically I'm killing him.
I killed him.
It counts, though.
Yeah, see?
I eliminated the contract and I got a new symptom.
him look at that i eliminated him yeah see look at that
aggression all right nice it counts see you guys i'm a
genius see i didn't forget look at that watch completed look
at that look at that guys all right let's go find the stupid
graffiti let's do this lore all right let's see if
flashlight I know one was here right I know it was here
somewhere I'm pretty sure was it here right
oh I need to find an order oh I didn't start my bunk yeah it
says one out of six
Yeah, see?
There I am.
Oh, here I go.
Oh, footsteps.
Where did the footsteps go?
Wait, where did it go?
Okay, footsteps.
Wait, where did the footsteps go?
Just the fucking pier.
Excuse me.
Uh.
Where the fuck did it go?
Okay.
Okay, here?
What?
I didn't see it.
I'm looking at the walls.
I'm fucking blind, man.
I'm actually blind.
I remember, I thought I found it here by the porta potty.
There's a porta potty.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I found it.
I'm so smart.
Okay, and then here.
And then...
Here.
And I'll remember.
Alright.
Where is the footprints leading me?
Any attempts to leave the zone without authorization will
result in immediate consequences.
Oh, there it is.
Found it.
Okay, then he walked back.
And then he keeps going.
And then back home?
He
went back home?
Oh, there it is.
I should have read a zombie queen.
Oh, my God, he went up.
Okay, parkour.
Okay, up here.
And he dropped down.
And he left.
And then...
Okay, buddy.
Okay, he went this way.
Okay.
And then...
Here you went.
Up the stairs.
Can't stop gossip.
What a show.
Stay calm and wait for your turn.
Alright, where did he go after that?
Yeah, no, he's trolling me, for real.
Okay.
Where did he go after that?
Okay, he walked out.
Now what?
Walked back this way?
Oh, there you go.
Still my me's drilling on Abe Crow.
Oh.
Abe Crow.
I don't remember that survivor.
Hey.
Don't feel a little rat.
Let me catch him or rip his ears off.
This place is a church.
Who the hell let him get his hands on the paint?
Who's in charge of the goddamn storage?
Wait, who is?
Check the storage.
I have a storage?
What's in there?
Oh, this is my storage.
I left the storage unlocked, and now we're missing some
paint cans.
Please, you gotta help me find them before the next
inspection.
this type of i thought i was trying to find this oh it's
damn near impossible to get it off you should still be able
to find traces of it with a flashlight are you serious final
vandal oh by the paint stains on their clothes oh all right
that's right who did it who done it it would never be you
crazy dave you too you're
You're just crazy.
Okay, she's just reading her book.
What about you?
You're just smoking.
I can explain.
The old fool brought it on himself.
He can't keep his mouth shut.
He's always picking fights and talking jokes behind
everyone's back.
I just wanted to teach him a lesson.
Make him know his place.
something out right i'll give the payback and you can say
you caught the troublemaker and punished him i've got money
please please don't look me in the eye come on look me in
the eye take the money or leave the residential lock wait if
i leave what happens oh there's the money oh
Ooh, how much money, though?
How much money is that?
It's not a lot.
You're right.
He says the military will give me more money.
You're so right, guys.
You're right.
The military will give me more money.
They've always been so kind to me.
You're so right, guys.
Thank you so much.
You're my savior.
Did he give me money?
Wait, where's my money?
What?
Um, I was promised money!
maybe he left it
I think I got scammed yeah and then I got scammed by the
military guys I don't understand after all those promotions
and yet no play race I I thought I was so appreciated but
was I not appreciated for a job well done
I fell for it again.
I...
She fell for it again.
Oh, government support.
Don't play possum, soldier.
I know you're up.
There's a new symptom.
There's another new symptom?
Oh my god, this virus keeps mutating.
New directives are available.
Check the bullet.
Didn't sleep, huh?
I can't blame you.
I've pretty much forgotten what a good night's sleep feels
like myself.
I keep waking up like I can't catch my breath.
Turns out you can spot the infection the same way.
Listen closely to how a person breathes.
And you'll figure out quick if they're sick.
What?
Holy shit, I gotta listen.
Okay, I'm gonna check.
identification verified what am i supposed to do with
solomon no incidents reported oh my god not to listen to him
breathe okay news that should check survivors breathing for
any eric high are telltale signs of infection okay show
spots breathing lungs are clear how the fuck oh is that okay
okay I get it I get it all right bring him in something that
doesn't sound right don't overthink it send the survivor to
the lab you'll be able to take a closer look at the symptom
there all right don't make me wait get over here all right
well I gotta check your breathing buddy Oh my gosh, so many
tears.
Okay, I guess I don't have to check your breathing.
But that does not sound right.
It looks like a fucking black spot for cancer, too.
He's got the black lung.
Um.
Oh, okay, it's like that.
Wait, sickly breath.
Wait, what?
What?
Wait, I thought...
What's the point?
Wait, what?
Oh, I didn't send you to the lab?
Alright, laptop.
I mean, you do have freckles as well.
Just to be safe.
Wait, Doki's coughing.
Hmm.
to be saved.
Oh, I'm so good at this now.
Wait.
Okay, I was going to say that one boot.
Alright, lab two, go!
Alright!
Come on.
Chop, chop.
It's lab time.
Yeah, but yeah.
He has a black spot on his lungs.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's...
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, that's so convenient.
Guys, that was so convenient.
Thank God.
Thank God your infection was not that bad.
Well, it was bad for you, but for me it wasn't that bad.
Oh.
then guys i think that was a good time to call it
and that was really honestly i think that was really fun i
can definitely play this like i want something that like
time like uh time to kill or something or they play on
twitch or something I think that would be really fun to play
just like a chilly game, but I wasn't worth the sacrifice I
think this was a perfect way to stop here for next week next
week's schedule um we'll have two God of War streams we're
going back to God of War uh we're trying to get as much
progress done um other than that uh we got booger bash 2 uh
we were not in the first booger bash but there's booger bash
2 that we're participating in which is a marble rivals
tournament um on i don't know what day it is that on the
29th or 30th i have no clue um that is all i have for next
that's all i could think of for next week so we'll see uh
we'll see i'll figure oh monday monday is high guard guys
monday we will be streaming the release of high guard i do
not know what time this game releases but like i don't know
everyone's everyone with no hashtag ad has been glazing the
game so this better be worth like i swear to god i don't
know if you guys saw it but um all my like every one
everybody does not put hashtag ad hashtag ad on their
twitter post glazing this game so i swear to god or that
would have been illegal i won't fall for it guys maybe maybe
it'll surprise us all maybe anyway guys thank you all for
watching uh and for accompanying me today uh for a long long
day i hope you guys enjoyed watching today's stream um i had
a lot of fun playing this game and i think i did a very good
job uh i just made one tiny oopsie just one anyway guys um
well maybe if he a lot maybe I wouldn't have sent him to the
lab he had a black spot he was gonna die anyway he literally
had a black spot in his lungs like he had no more time left
um it was I didn't execute anyone okay like I have a clean
record and guys as always everybody say hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you suffer me head to bed cause you it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.